how do you see things changing when IRL
tournaments pick up again um I don't
know I think personally I think it's
gonna be interesting again a lot of the
over the board chest tends to be in
Europe not in the United States so it
tends to require a lot of travel and
from my understanding talking to many
different people it doesn't seem likely
that there's gonna be international
travel for at least a few more months
it's not longer so when it comes back it
comes back but right now I think with
pogchamp scone on all the people who are
loving my streams I'm just having a
great time and and I'll worry about that
one time comes if right now I'm just you
know I'm just I'm loving twitch alright
well the games started just as you
finished so II 45 from Papa platta and
box box so far right so II 45 93 night 6
box box playing very solid can I see 3 I
assume box box will play Knight f6
unless he did specific preparation here
alright so he's playing this with the
black pieces and the white pieces we've
seen him do this at least the last two
games now yeah I'm not I'm not I'm not a
fan I'm not gonna lie I'm not a fan of
box box doing this setup with black with
the white piece I feel like it's more on
it's more thematic I think when you lose
the tempo and play this black it's a
little bit iffy I don't know if it's
necessarily gonna matter in the scheme
but I'm kind of worried that if he does
a setup like this in the in the matchup
against potentially his his big enemy
voyboy he could he could get into some
trouble again this is sorta is so he
plays h6 which is unnecessary Bishop g7
is better but he's a little bit worried
about an IG 5 type of move um so I
understand it but I do worried that he
got someone like void where hutch he
could get into trouble ok so box box
please d4 very good the platta plays d4
sorry papa planet right and now now
we're gonna see an interesting opening
cuz box box needs to find a couple of
good moves here to stabilize the
position or else he's gonna end up way
behind and development again he's pushed
three pawns Papa Plata has only pushed
two right and I think that Papa Plata
found d4 is very important here because
he grabs the D Center very early and it
seems like for some reason now he's
gonna have much more space because box
box is playing this so slowly right and
I think again
box box has to be very careful because
upon an age six is under attack long
term
let's see white goes Bishop to e3 or
moves tonight at some point Bishop III
Queen d2 lining up the lining up the
battery towards the pawn and h6 could
cause box box a lot of problems here and
do you think it would be better for Papa
Plata to go for Castle kingside in that
scenario based on the reason yeah
basically reading differential between
Papa plan and box box I feel that the
best chance for pop-up ladder to win is
to play aggressively and try to attack
so I would go for something that's as in
balance as possible in the best way to
get that is the castle of Queen on the
Queen side if possible fair enough well
he just retreated his knight he could
have also protected it how you mentioned
with Bishop e3 are taking the knight on
c6 but you know he saw that threat and
he's not worried about the bishop taking
on f3 because then he would really
damage and weaken the King III right yes
c3 I keep doing the arrows there that's
all good so we gonna listen in I guess
yeah let's let's take a listen on box
foxes stream
yeah let's do the usual
I know I like tuck Mike so he has a
system it seems that's why he keeps
playing it with white and black mm-hmm
yeah I like I like the general setup I
think it's gonna work very well so far
whether it works once we're in the
bracket stage I don't know but for the
moment I do like it very serious very
focused it's a stark difference from
when box locks is streaming and joking
around yeah he's very very serious very
stoic Papa platted decided to castle on
the kingside but still very safe
position from both so far yeah I just I
just like flat out lose this war if I do
that yeah so far we pretty I mean it
looks very balanced but I think the main
think box box has to remember oh no III
like very I've Airy lose that okay I
said that's for sure a war I do not want
to be fighting very good move by by box
box going John I like what he's doing
yeah I I like what he's doing this is
very very good so far and again the idea
is to move the King and then push the
pawn to f5 right he asked to move the
King away first because otherwise his
pawn is pinned as soon as he can do that
he can go for challenging the center you
can also take back with the bishop if
white ever changes I still like Queen d2
but it does seem less powerful now that
white has Castle kingside because you
can't really launch a pawn storm attack
where your king is Castle right exactly
so I still think we need to is a good
developing move maybe pawn to h3
although pushing the pawn to Asia is a
difficult move to play unless you've
been coach on the general setup of the
pawn formation once you've cast the King
both moves are good but it's gonna be
tricky here because box box is a very
straightforward plan and Papa platted
does not really it's like you want to
develop the pieces but it isn't concrete
cuz there are no open files true
I guess what would a more natural move
be for him though because he's already
finished in his development so now he's
starting to look for plans that are
going to carry him through the middle
game as well so he might end up seeing
something like that yeah I think Queen
d2 is is probably the most human move to
see just because you're creating an
attack on a piece but it is gonna be
hard here to figure out a plan I think
this is the hardest part in general even
from from giving giving advice to quite
a few these streamers how to play the
middle game what are the plans what are
the ideas because it if it's not
completely clear in terms of what you're
developing then it's very hard really to
conceptually like think it think it
through in the right ways so it's gonna
it's gonna be difficult but at the
moment he plays Ricky Wong which i think
is a completely reasonable move here
yeah and it's hard to train players in
the middle game the opening makes a bit
more sense because you're actually
expecting to see the specific positions
you're showing but as soon as they start
deviating into territory of positions
that they've never seen before
that's where it takes a lot more
practice yeah exactly
um so yeah I mean this is a tough
position to play because I think box box
has already looked at these structures a
lot with the pond this pond formation
okay that's kind of bold I like it
though even though it's objectively a
bad move I like it because it's gonna
confuse box box actually you can see his
look he's like he's got that tilted head
look like he's confused so it's probably
wait but wait Papa Platt has hit wait
wait wait papa cloud has his hands over
his face was that a mouse slip wait oh
no did you see that way where was that
mouse look cuz he has he had his hands
over his mouth was that a mouse slip
yeah very possible he was trying to go
for h3 instead from his audience
reaction
No oh no it wasn't okay anyway okay so
box box continues with f5 okay Chad is
telling me no he just does that okay all
right um well I don't know how often we
can trust Chad but I guess we have to
trust somebody here
are you really telling 60,000 people or
whatever the number is that there that
they try to mislead or won't be careful
sighs of course they do but they know
that it's part of the fun
okay so box box continues with f5 here
so they're both pushing the pawns near
their kings side this is a plan that box
box was going for regardless mm-hmm what
ideas do you think would be good for
Papa platta to continue his attack I I
think you should try to attack like
maybe pawn to h5 here I think would be
an aggressive move which I really like
again the position is kind of hard to
play it's very closed it's centered
around just like basic concepts for the
one good thing that I would add here is
that because box box has this King on h7
if he tries to bring the bishop down
with the pin there will always be a
Knight to g5 fossil check and then you
can win the bishop on c4 Knight g5
fossil check okay well those are some
deep ideas to see but I do think it's
natural to just continue pushing the
pawn once you've already gotten it to h4
he did play Bishop e5 instead which is a
strange move because his Bishop was well
placed on c4 and he shouldn't actually
try to attack the knight on c6 yeah so
okay so now Knight takes pawn should be
played here I assume that he will see it
that's a very thematic move it's the
nothing is really under attack or very
cheap piece in the center here so I
think one thing that's good for box box
yeah so now this is what I was gonna say
so the black was Bishop g4 here then you
have night at g5 making the fossil and
I'm winning the bish bunchy for Bishop
g4 and it is a natural looking move
although what it's actually a very
natural move but my point was because
the king is on h7 where it normally
isn't that that's like it lends itself
to this check where is because the king
is normally not there box box would
probably automatically play Bishop g4 so
I think in this case on 4
Papa Claddagh it's very nice that the
King isn't on g8 and that it's on each
seven says Bishop Bishop g4 it you end
up losing and chap by the way a fossil
check is the new term for a discovered
check after two thousand years we need
to update the terminology and it's no
longer a discovered check it's a faucet
shot cuz you discover fossils yeah
because you make a chart yeah exactly
well I don't know ask X you see I mean I
think that's a pretty straightforward
way to think about it box box grabs the
pond on v2 instead so he's just going
pond grabbing here now he's forcing papa
platen to rook p1 it's an intuitive move
and the only decent move here other than
if there's some type of crazy attack
that I wouldn't expect any human to see
here other than maybe you Hikaru yeah I
mean I I actually really would like for
box box oh sorry Papa Platt if you go
all in and play a move like pawn to h5
with the idea h5 g5 and just sacking a
knight and trying to go for a checkmate
because it's it's really the best chance
he's gonna have to UM to win those games
because I'm excited to sacrifice
somebody else's pieces here it's a joke
we make us commentators about how we'd
love to see these kinds of positions all
right he goes for rippy one um but he
you know he still has that option in the
future as well for going with h5 right
and this is the thing that I think that
Papa cloud needs to do is he needs to
attack he's behind by one pawn right
here so he really needs to look for
ideas to attack this black King which is
very vulnerable with these two with only
the two pawns in front of it for
protection
okay so let's say box box puts his
Bishop on g7 I forgot to ask you the
usual questions of what chances would
you put that box box wins this game um
the chances overall I think are pretty
high but one thing that I've really
liked from Papa platta is that for the
most part he's been very consistent he's
made very few like major mistakes I know
they gave us a lot of way he made one
really big mistake with the Queen but
he's been pretty solid and it's just
like one or two mistakes somewhere in
the middle if you can avoid those one or
two mistakes I think I do think box box
is still a big favor probably I would
say about like I don't know I would say
like II 85 percent to win this game is
what I would say but again Papa cloud
has been very very consistent so if you
can just avoid
making serious mistakes and keep the
game close especially as both players
got lower on the clock I think anything
can happen well I see Papa platta
continuing to hover his mouse over the
bishop but now he just pointed to the
idea h5 if he season with like h5 he has
some serious attacking chances ooh
he traded he would have really needed
his LightSquared Bishop after moved like
h5 to help get in on the attack yeah
this is true but at the same time what I
would say about the position is that
it's not clear what the ideas are for
black and again if it box box he uses
too much time and gets along the clock I
think you could see some serious
mistakes on Commission of g4 right this
is the obvious one but again it's it's
hard to see Knight g5 as well so I think
the game remains pretty pretty balanced
I mean actually after Bishop d3 I wonder
if white wasn't actually better in a way
but anyway he took on c6 so 96 right
that's what I'm expecting box box is
thinking here which is interesting so
let's go take another look at box boxes
stream these or this square
mmm-hmm I think I'm actually so stick
with pawn here these squares are better
for attacking okay so he wants to bring
his knight in that's why yeah it's a
very it's a very good move cuz also
there's no attack now from the rook on
v1 yeah I can't protect those those
green squares so his bishop won't be
tied into protecting
I mean worry is that he's already gotten
his rook into the open file so that
advantage is no longer there okay so I
have my game plan this pawn is so loose
all I have to do is just drive this
Knight off somehow I wonder if we're
gonna see if he gets Bishop g4 oh crap I
could have done that if it I could have
done that if I took
oh wait the night's gone she looks a
little shocked yeah I think certainly he
is shocked on the night the night is in
the center now
oh my god its base destroying time we
can we can execute our plan okay so it
sounds like he wants to take this I'm
not too scared if he takes that I don't
really care about my right my queen side
of the board what do you think of his
bold strategy to give up his pawn I
think it's it's the best move position
it's one of the simplest moves also to
get more of an attack going so I really
do like the move wait a second I see
something kind of interesting oh wait no
I don't if I do this where's his not
going okay I believe first I should push
this Knight back so it looks like he's
going to play d5 here which is also a
pretty natural move to try to kick the
knight out of the center but it does
give the knight the c5 square yeah it's
uh not the best move and yeah I think it
Papapa defines Knight c5 it's game on
because now the Knights control the
squares in the center the knight is
going to e6 and this is game on
if table plateau finds Knight to c5
there are some very serious threats now
and with the time getting low oh that's
just the free piece yeah so this is what
I was gonna say his papa platter one
thing that's been really nice to see is
that he's playing generally very sound
was not blundering unfortunately it
feels like it one or two points in the
middle he always makes one or two
mistake he makes one or two of these
mistakes from which you really can't
recover from and it's like you see like
you see like as soon as he does it he
realizes and so I mean it takes a lot of
lot of mental fortitude and I'm sort of
the pressure of finding move after move
without making mistake it's difficult
but again I think that certainly going
forward he just needs if he can find a
way to keep that concentration and focus
for a few more moves and get and avoid
making his big mistakes he's gonna have
a shot
a shot against NIMH I would say so like
here c5 Knight c5 but it's one move to
lakes they made the blunder first Hey
there are a lot of promising signs for
Papa Potter definitely I'm very I am
very impressed as when I first saw him
coming into the vent playing on three
before getting any coaching I felt that
he would be one of the players who might
struggle more but he's been doing very
very well
well let's also take a look in on his
stream in that case so you're pulling up
Papa Plata here okay you can do hydrogen
aim I'm not gonna DNA my kind of destiny
I was getting these deer hanged you can
use your German now explain what he's
thinking not another piece come on Papa
[Music]
feels bad
oh my god oh sorry Chad dude it
hey the manatees mention me that timeout
action again sighs yes sir okay well
voxbox
cruel doesn't even take the bishop right
oh but he I think if you watch box walks
he rises he missed the bishop like do we
see box wants an expression like he
realizes that he missed it
oh no box box I thought he was trying to
be tricky I mean Bishop G Street is a
hard move to deal with here no blender
blender fest today that's a little tough
oh-ho-ho however he is still winning the
game I think fortunately for him it's
not a mistake of that's gonna change the
outcome I don't think but certainly it's
gonna affect him mentally the fact that
he missed that free bishop right I
wonder if he was getting a little too
comfortable there I mean he already won
one piece he's going for the attack he
just didn't think as long as he could
have
yeah I mean it's it's difficult but
again he's still he's still doing well I
think this is one thing I found with box
boxes he tends to he's too hard on
himself from what I've seen and he just
he needs to kind of not be so hard on
himself and let it sort let the game
come to him a bit more because he's
expecting perfection and perfection
doesn't really exist at the at the level
he's absolutely I think he just needs to
you know take a deep breath Verizon
still winning the game and just just
stay calm not let the time situation
affect him either it's very important on
here to not let the clock affect his
decisions well let's listen to his
thought process now on that note I think
I'm just going back
I can also go right here oh I'm running
out of time oh there they both have two
minutes on the clock
saying this is kind of what I'm saying
is that basically there's it's it's very
nerve-racking I think at this point for
for box box he rises the clock yeah and
chat realizes the clock oh wait
thank you all right here so yes a few
good options here there if he puts its
Queen on g5 you'll at least attack the
night it was well I started on blender
I'm a long time this is a very good move
to attacking the night across the board
yeah Papa Plata's has hung in there very
well so far and if it box box if pop lab
doesn't make any more mistakes I still
think this the result is in doubt it's
not completely clear yet what's gonna
happen so with a time situation who do
you think is better in these time
crunches from what you've seen so far
Oh I mean box box box boxes thank you
better say objectively because he's he's
studied more he's played more games he's
more experienced when both players got
low on time the experience plays a very
big role certainly for for finding good
moves when you don't have time on the
clock so it does favor box box but again
the position is not completely clear so
I think anything can happen
although Papa platta takes the pawn okay
so box box is going going for the
checkmate with Bishop h3 now now this is
a difficult position if Papa platta
can't find Bishop back to g3 it's the
game is still going on um but it's hard
it's a hard move when you're new to the
game to see this or backwards moves with
bishops especially um so it's the best
move but it's hard to find it's not a
natural looking move and it's not a move
that I that I really don't expect to
fight if he finds it I will be very
impressed well that would be one last
fight a fighting attempt and he did see
it that's all very nice
very nice I think the reason you found
it is because when you're about to get
checkmated you really go through and
exhaust all of the options right but he
found it very quickly - he didn't use a
lot of time I think the main reason to
the all sizes Bishop just came from that
Square so so he remember it was right
there but it's a very good move and what
is the time 129 to 55 really really uh
yeah this is now this is where let's see
a Papa platta can find the night move to
attack the Queen so 94 or 96 they both
look pretty challenging here he might as
well go for one of these sharp lines and
if the bishop takes the Queen he takes
the Queen his check and then he can
recapture and at least he's still
fighting he may be down a piece this is
this is very impressive I think so now
make sure take the Queen which I think
he will see um but he should see it I
think he will sit yeah absolutely a
platter actually I don't because because
I think he was because he speaks German
he hasn't taken lessons I think with you
or I or anything right speaking
streamers it's hard to judge how how
much training he's had with a little bit
of train but even if it's only a little
bit it's been very this is very good to
see the way you found ninety-six saving
the knight from being under attack on c5
was very very good and this is this has
been a very very good game from from
Papapa even though he blundered very
early on and the only issue here is the
clock thirty seconds he's got he's got
to get going
he's ready get going class moves even a
four rook d7 would have been a nice move
or I mean rupee seven now is even better
because at least he's threatening the
night and the pawn but I'd rather see
him play quickly than super accurately
right he's just got to make moves the
clock really is gonna play a role here
right and shout out to the chest
category on Twitch having around a
hundred fifty thousand people watching
that's almost half of just chatting
category which is insane since I think
just chatting has been the highest
viewed
mm-hmm yeah it's amazing December
people-watching chest certainly um oh
okay he blundered in exchange that's not
that's not good here now he's down a
full rook yeah I think unfortunately now
he's probably gonna lose a game but what
I would say is that even though even
though as I predicted before box box is
a huge favorite win this game this has
been a very very impressive performance
from a Papa pada he's played a lot of
very good moves despite despite the one
or two major mistakes he's made most of
the moves he's played have been have
been quality moves so I've been very
impressed by it bye bye Papa Coty's
performance in this game right even if
he did lose we talked a lot about how
when you go up against someone so much
stronger getting into the end game we're
really putting on a fight and for him he
only blundered when he got into time
pressure
okay weighted box let's just promote to
a rook yeah I mean I think he's just
being funny yeah yeah just trying to get
three Brookes on the board right you
have to trade off anyway so I didn't
matter yeah yeah but this has been this
has been a very very good performance
for Papa Tata well we're ready to take a
look at ox box again lots a nice
elements though I guess what the two
works you can't really sell them at the
king
yeah box box is just like yeah I see the
checkmate wait why do you go rook before
though oh wait I have checked me he
didn't let me doing I love how he still
has his animations on yeah I was nice
let's take all this funds it's like a go
promote a bunch of pieces though yeah
okay yeah no he wasn't trying the
request was cute to have three of those
on the board there well Papa plateaux
put up a very nice fight box box did is
the stronger opponent the more
experienced opponent so it wasn't too
much of a surprise to see the result we
did but still impressive performance
from both yeah I mean again I think I
don't I don't feel like Papa Plata's had
a lot of training so most of the moves
that he found in this game I really did
like he made his he made one or two
moves of course a blunders but he still
found some good moves like the 96 move I
thought was a very hard move to find
considering that his Queen was under
attack so I thought I thought pop apply
to play quite well the only thing that
he really is
avoid doing or maybe like not avoid but
try not to do its just stay folks and
try to avoid that one or two those one
or two moves in the middle of some
portion of those videos or not videos
those moves have kind of cost him in
some of the some of the critical moments
but all right bringing up I'm bringing
up that blender also as you talked about
this so I moved 16 after d5 was pushed
he was attacking the knight on e4 and he
instead took on c6 I don't know what the
slip was here but it's hard one moment
yeah mm-hmm focus and you just throw the
entire game yeah I mean that's what
makes just so hard it's such a simple
game in terms of the rules but avoiding
you know making mistake hanging a knight
or hang a bishop or a queen like that's
what makes just fun is that it's it's
very hard to avoid making these sorts of
mistakes on and again I thought for the
most part probably plateau played a very
good game he just he made a couple moves
that unfortunately cost League anybody
put up a great fight and I was very
impressed by his performance today and
we are back we're joined by box box and
Papa Plata who put up a really good
fight in this game - that night blender
well what happened there I don't know I
saw the time and I was struggling a bit
because I saw old folk I don't have that
much time left so yeah I I pressed the
button too fast I guess I don't know oh
that's that that's fair time pressure is
really hard to deal with and soon after
you put your bishop on a square where
box box could have captured it but box
locks he took the pawn instead
did you miss Murray going for an attack
i tunnel vision very hard I had my eye
on that pawn for six turns as soon as I
could take I did that's fair we we
listened in on you talking about how you
wanted to go for that pawn weakness so I
can understand what happened with the
tunnel visioning there also we were
taking a look at your opening so box box
you keep playing a very similar
structure with g6 and h6 right away can
you tell us more about why you picked it
yeah the main reason is like because
people better than
told me to fight if you were to ask me
to like explain why it's like strong
yeah why you or why you like playing it
I guess your coach told you and you said
okay let's do it yeah it's um it's it
was an easy system to memorize where
there's like the first nine moves are
almost always exactly the same and
usually do them in slightly different
orders based on what your opponent does
and I like having that comfort because I
I've been historically blundering away
in the first nine moves almost every
game almost every game was like lost
before like the opening finished or I
lost like half of my time so I got this
something to automatically just get
through it and he car do you want to
comment on box foxes move for h6 since
he plays this every game your invite
advice here would be very helpful so I
was actually kind of curious uh why you
pushes pawn was it because of your
previous match against Swift or in which
Swift where has this idea of moving the
night down at g4 to attack your earth to
pond and here you saw Knight g5
attacking your f7 pawn or wasn't what
one of the coaches showed you I I've
actually never made this move that early
it was it was because I learned that
this system when playing second it
doesn't work as well it only works in to
some situations and I really did not
want this to be a game where I couldn't
do that so I I did not want him to move
his knight up and then do the fried
chili attack close it up close yeah
because what you could have done
actually has moved your Bishop your
knight and then you canceled your king
if white tries to attack the pawn so you
could have saved one move actually no no
I know Albert puts tonight on a nice uh
but not a six so ninety seven and if
Knight g5 you can just castle the king
and you defend the pawn with your rook
oh because in the game what you did by
pushing the pawn you actually lose one
move and to his credit Papa platic did
play pawn to d4 which was a very very
good moocs that's being aggressive since
you since you wasted an extra move in
the opening by pushing the pond sorry
the keyboard was a very good move
opening up the center you're actually
one move behind here whereas you could
have had the bishop on g7 and the knight
on e7 so potentially you could have
ended up in a lot of trouble if instead
of
three go back one move yep
here we go so you could mr. g7 right and
Bishop to e3 here would have been a very
nice move the point being that black
moves the knight to e7 you can now go
Queen to d2 and you're putting pressure
on this pawn on the dark square in the
corner because of black castles that
pawn is gonna be hanging down the road
okay it's pretty advanced but it's just
like like Papa cloud is d4 move after
you push pawns a very very good move
it's just a matter of knowing the follow
but I really did like did like a lot of
the opening this room from from Papa
platter right and box lock since you
play this system as white and black
probably knowing this counter idea
against white should be very helpful or
maybe we just told all your opponent's
well they can try to do I'm not sure
which of the two two seven
but Papa platta he played very strong
after d4 was an awesome move and night
if Knight of three we understood that he
didn't want to get under attack there
Papa Bell platter do you feel like your
main trouble in this game was just
dealing with the time situation um no
not that but mmm
I think box box is a better player than
me so I was a bit on pressure I guess
yeah not sure maybe I haven't practiced
enough so I only played two days this
week I guess I could have played more
well it was still a good fight and
you're both going to go to the
championship bracket box box I know you
were one of the favorites to qualify and
you performed you're going for voyboy
but Papa Claddagh you have been one of
like the most over performing players in
the entire tournament where you are you
surprised to make it to the championship
bracket at all yes yes save oh well
congratulations you really deserved it
he card do you have any last questions
yeah I mean I was just gonna say I
thought actually from standpoint for you
papa cloud I thought your perform
was very very good and even in the
scheme clearly you were you were the
underdog your opponents had a lot more
experience playing chess but you found a
lot of very good moves and you were very
stable in that middle part you just made
this one mistake where you lost the
knight but for the most part you you've
been very solid and not making a lot of
mistakes so I think if you just keep
doing that you're gonna you're gonna
have a shot don't don't count yourself
out in the upcoming match against them
thank you very much well thank you so
much Fox Fox Papa platta and best of
luck to both of you in the championship
bracket Thanks thank you